Speaker 1: . There's a really interesting
piece I saw yesterday morning in the Hill
written by Alexander Bolton that's called
Republican Worry's Republican Party Worries
Fiscal Conservatism is losing its rallying
cry.
And the article says a few interesting things.
The big picture of which is the fiscal conservatism
that for so long was a big piece of the Republican
Party mantra or ideology or policy framework
may be losing its sort of power and strength
as a unifying factor for the Republican Party.
And Bolten writes instead, culture war issues
like immigration, religious freedom, LGBTQ
rights, big tech and Black Lives Matter are
taking center stage in conservative politics,
saying that, quote, The initial shift in Republican
political priorities away from belt tightening
coincided with the demise of the Tea Party,
the dominant force in the 2010 2010 midterm
elections, and the rise of now former President
Trump, who presided over an eight trillion
dollar increase in the national debt.
I agree this is happening.
I think that it actually started far earlier.
In a sense, Reagan, while very fiscal conservatism
focused, started the path of the shift to
the cultural and social issues.
Reagan did it by starting to talk about the
welfare queen with the Cadillac and all the
kids just to make some food stamp money.
And that led to Newt Gingrich, who pushed
the Republican Party more in the direction
of the culture and social issues, which then
led to George W. Bush, who was essentially
incompetent economically and from a foreign
policy standpoint, but was big on he's against
abortion and he's born again and all this
different stuff.
And then we got to Donald Trump.
So so while I completely agree that this happened,
I think the timeline is actually a much more
nuanced and longer timeline.
But needless to say, the analysis is correct.
Alexander Bolton goes on to say, now Republicans
are having a tough time generating the same
outrage over Biden's multitrillion dollar
spending agenda as they did over former President
Obama's signature initiatives, the American
Relief and Reinvestment Act and the Affordable
Care Act, which cost far less than what Biden
is proposing on infrastructure.
I think that there's another aspect to that.
I don't think that it's because of Republican
hypocrisy that now they aren't that opposed
or actually are in favor of Joe Biden's one
point nine dollars, one point nine trillion
dollar stimulus, or Joe Biden's planned infrastructure
spending, which also has some significant
Republican support.
It's not that Republicans are saying, you
know, when Trump blew up the deficit, we were
OK with it.
So maybe Joe Biden doing it isn't so bad.
I don't think it's that at all.
It's that the country is actually just all
united on those issues and always has been.
And the political clout or influence that
the Republican Party had by criticizing the
spending is simply not having the same impression.
I don't think it's the voters that have changed.
I think it's that the Republican elected officials
have become less able to generate outrage
over it.
We've seen no evidence that they actually
care about the hypocrisy.
It's just that the Republican Party, given
everything that's going on, given how even
many in the Republican Party electorate now
understand that huge income inequality is
not so good, they understand that, you know,
deficit just for the sake of saying deficit
is bad is not something most of them are falling
for.
I think that it's the electorate that has
actually come to realize that they've been
fed best by their party, not that their views
have dramatically changed.
And it used to be a sort of rallying cry that
really got people fired up.
And now it's just not if you go back, Eisenhower
was the last Republican president to preside
over a balanced budget.
He balanced the budget in 1956 and 1957.
And since then, it's been two Democrats that
balanced the budget, LBJ in 69 and Clinton
during 1998 to 2001, followed by George W.
Bush taking over and exploding the deficit.
So when you look at how the balanced budget
actually is far more.
And under Democratic presidents than Republicans,
you realize that the Republican Party's two
main economic policies cut taxes and spend
on the military don't actually count as fiscal
conservatism.
They were never really about fiscal conservatism.
They were about talking about fiscal conservatism.
And then a basic, you know, finance 101, Econ
101, when you say, OK, the policy is you cut
taxes as much as possible, reduce revenue,
and then you spend more on the military, that
that's not actually fiscally conservative
and now they're not even pretending to be
about that.
So I agree very much with what Alexander Bolton
concludes here, which is the Republican Party
is right to worry that fiscal conservatism
as a rallying cry and unifying sort of policy.
It's not even really a policy idea.
It's a framework.
It's a bullet point of some kind.
It's no longer working.
And you have many Republicans approving of
Biden's stimulus plan, many Republicans approving
of Biden's proposed infrastructure plan.
They're going to have to come up with something
else.
They seem to be going in the direction of
making it these culture issues.
The question is whether even that will work
because support for movements like Black Lives
Matter is up even among the right.
Not by that much, not by that much.
But all of the hammering on BLM by the right
hasn't decreased support hasn't increased
much, but it hasn't decreased it.
So I don't actually know what they need to
do to win the hearts and minds of voters,
which explains perfectly why they are focusing
on suppressing the vote.
They're realizing they're having trouble winning
any other way.
And so you suppress the vote, you try to win
in that way.
And that's exactly what they admitted they
were going to do back in 2012.
You go to the video of Mike Turzai, Pennsylvania,
saying voter ID is going to help Mitt Romney
win some states.
That's not Mitt Romney is going to come up
with great ideas.
It's not Mitt Romney understands what it is
that the average American wants.
Its voter ID will help Mitt Romney win.
It didn't.
He lost badly to Barack Obama.
But this was all predictable.
It's been predictable for a decade and it
is happening right now.
The question is, do they double down on the
voter suppression or do they start trying
to win on policy?
It seems that they're doing the voter suppression.